there's more than one way to skin a cat
and just like that there is more than
one way to build muscle but different
types of muscle building will result in
different types of muscle this is
something a lot of people don't realize
when they first get into their training
and sometimes even when they're quite a
long way into their routine depending on
your goals you need to choose the right
type of training to seat you at the same
time depending on your metabolism on
your muscle fiber type you need to also
choose the right type of muscle training
for you and if you want me and you want
to train for cross modalities and get as
many different things in that basket as
possible then you need to mix these up
into one big thing so whether you're
planning for athletics aesthetics or
athletic aesthetics you need to know
what the best way to achieve that is and
I'm going to talk about that in this
videos my guest so stay tuned and let's
do that cutting thing that I made
okay so you might now be wondering what
I was blabbering about in that highly
well spoken introduction this is
something people often ask me they say
oh why are you speaking about I'm going
to tell you now I mean it is a bit of a
complex subject
hence my blabbering so perhaps the
easiest way to demonstrate is to just
show you an example of two different
training modalities and then explain how
they get diplomatic results so on the
one hand you have lifting heavy weights
for a smaller amount of repetitions this
is a way that I can do a few times let's
go alright so what we're doing here all
right I pulled you a couple more
repetitions no more than eight I'd say
maximum so what we're doing there is
we're engaging the fastest twitch muscle
fibers these are the fibers in the
muscle that concrete lives explosive
power they're the least energy efficient
but for pure power they're the most
useful and so when you lift something
very heavy your body tries to engage as
many of those fast twitch muscle fibers
as possible now compare this with doing
a lighter weight like so now I'm using
the slow twitch muscle fibers the body
will try and do the most efficient thing
it can do in order to get you through
your chosen task so if you're moving a
lot of weight it will make you use the
most explosive muscle fibers but if it
can get away with using the slow twitch
muscle fibers which more energy
efficient then it will when the faster
muscle fibers won't be involved but
there are more differences involved here
than simply which type of muscle type
fiber you're tearing at the same time
when you have to heavier weight this
requires a better neuromuscular
connection it requires better mind
muscle
connection as they sometimes call it
this means you need to recruit more
muscle fibers and that is partly due to
how strong the connections are on your
brain and any nervous system and that
happens to be practice they say that the
average folk can only recruit about 30%
of their muscle fiber when they're
trying to lift a heavy weight so they're
leaving 70% of their maximum strength on
the table
the trained athlete on the other hand
can recruit about 50% why don't you just
recruit hundred-seven with your fast
twitch muscle fiber because if you did
that you'll be fully exhausted you're
going to use your faster Trussell burger
at all and then if the predator came
you'll be able to run away there are
some interesting studies that show that
adrenaline can increase the amount of
fast twitch muscle fiber you're capable
of recruiting and that's why you hear
stories about women lifting cars up
their tracks children and rock climbers
pushing rocks off of their bodies for
the most part they training with heavy
weight will help you to improve your
muscle fiber recruitment as well as
tearing the fast twitch muscle fibers
tearing the muscles is what leads them
to grow during rest when your body uses
the protein to build those muscle fibers
thicker meanwhile there's more going on
with a lighter weight - when you train
with a lighter weight then we're not
only training the search with muscle
fibers which by the way in a thinner
type meaning that they won't build as
big and as thick at the same time
they're also allowing you to do a higher
number of repetitions which means you're
probably getting a little bit of
climbing benefit but moreover it means
you're creating metabolic stress when
you do this you're effectively occluding
the muscle blood now can't escape from
the bicep it's being sent there and it's
building up along with metabolites such
as growth hormone and testosterone and
it's increasing and depleting the
glycogen stores in the muscle some
people divide these two types of
training into myofibrillar hypertrophy
hypertrophy being muscle growth and
sarcoplasmic hypertrophy my finger
another real means that you're tearing
the muscle fibers and that increases
strength raw strength and the UI of
sarcoplasmic means that you're building
the muscles up with fluid and that
increases size
and that's what body mother's tend to do
if it was a powerlifter tends to focus
more on my river life there is some
debate as to whether or not these
concepts are scientifically sound but I
think anyone who's worked out in the gym
will tell you the lighter weight perform
for higher repetitions will lead to
greater muscle volume muscle size
whereas heavier weight the fewer
repetitions will increase your overall
strength and that's probably mainly due
to the fast twitch muscle fiber tearing
it's also due to the improved technique
and the improved ability to croute those
muscle fibers so on one hand you have
your power lifters palaces of people
they tend to use compound movements
these are big movements that involve
multiple muscle multiple joints let's
say called a multi joint exercise so
they would combining all of their
different joints to work in unison and
this creates a bigger flood of growth
hormone they use very heavy weights they
train for a lower number of repetitions
they're interested in creating muscle
tears building the neuromuscular
Junction and generally improving their
overall strength you can get very skinny
power lifters and they're just so good
because they have the perfect technique
and they can recruit more muscle fiber
there's a guy called Dennis Rogers he's
a strong man and he can recruit a huge
amount of muscle fiber despite being a
small guy he seems to have a genetic
advantage and in doing this he may be a
well strongest man pound for pound they
don't give it Hank you have bodybuilders
and what they'll tend to do is just
isolate a muscle group now they give you
compound exercises as well but
predominantly they focus on isolation
exercises like the curl and in doing
this the only muscle you're using is the
bicep if you're using correct form this
allows you to create a maximum number of
micro tears in that specific muscle
while at the same time flooding it with
the metabolites that will stimulate your
ex-girl even and now will result in the
sarcoplasmic hypertrophy
that creates size and the aesthetics
that bodybuilders are named for now a
lot people say that's not functional
what it goes on
they've got this useless strength it's
fake muscle that's nonsense that's
annoying because what's wrong with
endurance endurance lifting is a useful
skill and as you flood your muscles with
more fluids they become better endurance
tasks thus a bodybuilder would be
superior if you had to turn a heavy
wheel for two hours which rigidly is
something you'd only regularly but then
to be honest II don't regularly have to
it to a kilogram logoff before either so
you know horses for courses and that's
where my next point comes in because one
of your horse who wants to run on all
the courses you're a multidisciplinary
horse in that case you might want to try
something like power building power
building means you combine both types of
training into one workout so you might
do the white White's power repetitions
and you might do the heavier weights for
fewer repetitions you might do isolation
and combine that with compound movements
and this is called power building
because you're building the aesthetics
and we're building the power that comes
from power building and this way is
won't really insurance as well it's more
explosive power and this is very similar
to what people are currently calling on
the Internet athletic aesthetics that
means training for performance and for
size but then this could also be related
to even more interdisciplinary training
such as CrossFit or anything across with
where you're combining things like
powered with also running and
calisthenics and all this other stuff
Street workouts so you can binding all
that different stuff into one regime and
it's up to you which bits you want to
prioritize what do you want to do all of
it whether you want to just focus on one
bit nothing is wrong and nothing is
right we're all unique and that's what
makes the world nice or something I
don't like but what I like to do is try
and combine all these different types of
training not only because I'm interested
in improving my overall performance but
also because I do believe it's the best
way to stimulate growth because what
you'll find is depending on how much
faster shots or fiber you have how much
so much muscle fiber you have whether
you're an ectomorph an endo more
whatever kind of growth hormone
profiling path or when prefer this will
affect which kind of training is best
for you some people will find that as
soon as they slim down
to the max that they then start to see
massive growth of her the lots of people
say that in fact I made a video on it
slow down your trading then you might
just see great other people on the other
hand will find that straining faster is
what they need to stimulate most growth
other people still might respond best to
compound movements other people respond
best to isolation movements and so
before you start training you don't know
what's going to work for you then I say
well why not just do all of it then when
I combine it all into one regime that's
what I like to do and then there's all
these other exciting types of training
that I find really interesting a lot of
people say the best way to build
strength to create muscle damage and
therefore micro-tears
is to have the weight on the negative
portion of the movement and to apply
pressure during the stretch so like so I
would do it isometric hold gradually let
my muscles fail let's speed that up a
bit and make sure that I go all the way
to that stretch and I submit I'm doing
bench press or something if i widen my
grip and feel that stretch that often
these the most Dom's the next day
delayed onset muscle soreness and the
most growth then you have things like
static contraction or overbearing
isometrics ever coming isometrics that's
where you are pulling against an
immovable force
so something Bruce Lee used to do he
used to just pull against a chain so
it's attached to the floor see how hard
he can pull it and that would what
that'll do is it was allowing him to do
the equivalent of training with way
beyond his 1 rep max because he's
pulling as much as he can possibly pull
he's trying to recruit all that muscle
fiber but the brain is sending out
signals a sitar : and therefore he's
increasing his muscle fiber recruitment
and this is why Bruce Lee despite being
a relatively small guy was as powerful
as you know you could possibly probably
want to be and that's going to be go
kick which I did but yes sir that looks
too and then it goes sort of everything
recently horse is the speed training and
speed training
involved as yes just going to work out
as fast as possible and this is
interesting because as far as muscles
are concerned generating the explosive
power and force doesn't matter whether
that's juice resistance or those due to
acceleration your body thinks that
acceleration is the same thing as
resistance and there's way more and I
could go into it in detail but I only
Memphis being rather long the point is
to me the most exciting the interesting
trading is when you combine all these
things into one awesome regime and the
way I do that is to build it around a
drop set because a drop set to me is
already the perfect power building
protocol because what you're doing is
you're starting with a very heavy weight
and this is recruiting maximum muscle
fiber creating maximum tears and you go
into failure you can't do any more
repetitions when you reach failure you
put down that weight and you immediately
pick up the next one and what happens
then is that you cause all the micro
tears you fatigue those faster muscle
fibers so when you go down awake you're
now bringing in still the fastest fibers
that were fatigued by the last one like
I say you're using the most efficient
combination of muscle fibers so you're
just seeking more and you're starting to
bring in your Morbius weight which
muscle fibers at the same time because
you've now then two sets back-to-back
with no break in between that's
increasing your time and attention and
the time allowed for your muscle to
build up that blood isn't a blight and a
drop set hazards keep on going through
those motions so then what I do is I
just tap on my other types of training
don't like stuff with my overcoming Isis
metrics or an isometric hold then move
on alright this is too heavy but for the
purpose of it
illustration great technique there then
move on to the next place I can dig and
then stairs I can't do any more of that
move on to the next lighter one and keep
going and then you keep going and keep
going that's called running wrap and
then on my end with birds or on my end
with another isometric hold on my friend
was just contracting the muscles or I
make the stretch
at the end we'll just really stretch out
the muscles as much as I can by building
this woman's one giant set you're
including all types of training and as
one of the most key principles of
bodybuilding States said Cesaro ask
specific adaptations to impose demands
that is right as that tells you your
body will adapt to whatever fan of
training you third it you so all the
kinds of training at it then it will
adapt to all of them as you know from my
previous video both sides go running as
well which is my cardio fitness allows
me to train harder and increases my
resting heart rate in between to
stimulate more growth so this is quite a
long rambling video the point is that
I'm gonna say there's lots of different
types of training the type of special
you depends on your goals and it depends
on your body the best approach I think
to get the best all-around body and to
avoid disappointment it's combined all
into one mega routine and that's what I
do and I'll be talking more about how to
do that and I'll show you some workouts
I do to do that on my channel later but
also just keep your searching on certain
things don't be too west where you want
training regime and yet if you
experimenting don't be afraid to combine
lots of different things into one so
there you go that's that I guess so yeah
in essence training lots of awesome
different ways and it will be awesome I
hope you found that useful and
interesting if you did please consider
liking and subscribing please consider
following me on Twitter and on Instagram
and I put my links to those things in
the description below obviously check
out the website at the binary calm and
stay tuned to this channel for lots more
of this kind of thing and also lots of
other kinds of things because I'm only
talking about lifestyle design
nootropics and all sorts of ways to
boost your body and your brain because
that's what I'm interested in and
hopefully you find it interesting too so
yes stay tuned for that thanks very much
for watching and I will see you next
time bye for now